on Wednesday news broke that Steven
twitch boss died from a self-inflicted
gunshot wound and now ET has learned
that the former Ellen Show DJ left a
note behind indicating that he couldn't
go on
ET confirmed that on Monday twitch
checked into the Oak Tree Inn in Encino
California a motel less than a mile from
his home when he didn't check out at
11AM on Tuesday Morning housekeeping and
management knocked on his door
repeatedly before opening the door and
calling the police twitch's death was
also confirmed by his wife Allison
holker in a statement to ET where she
reflected on her husband's Life and
Legacy writing that he lit up every room
he stepped into quote he valued family
friends and Community Above All Else and
leading with love and light was
everything to him I have the sweetest
husband in the entire world Allison
concluded her emotional statement with
one final message we love you we miss
you and I will always Save the Last
Dance For You I feel like we connect a
lot through dance so it's just sometimes
fun like to have a partner in life that
I can also dance with you know it just
makes every single day so fun now Azores
close to the fan family tells E.T
Allison is surrounded by a lot of
friends and family and is trying to cope
as best she can for their kids Allison
and twitch have two children together
six-year-old son Maddox and
three-year-old daughter ziya twitch is
also dad to holker's 14 year old
daughter Wesley from a previous
relationship we love the Full House and
also just like family man like honestly
they're my favorite they're my favorite
people you know what I mean following
news of his death reports surface that
the family was in bad shape financially
but our source says any rumors about
their finances being out of order are
completely false meanwhile twitch's
famous friends continue grieving his
loss he's never going to be out of my
life he's he's always a part of my life
I love the family that we've gone to and
um something that I always remember is
that you gave me a place
or I could just be myself Ellen
DeGeneres shared an emotional clip to
Instagram Thursday writing that she
wanted to remember all the love and
laughter they shared
that's absolutely
which served as the house DJ on The
Ellen Degeneres Show from 2014 until the
series ended earlier this year he even
added the title executive producer to
his name I'm still in a lot of shock
um my daughter is really close with
Wesley his daughter and our kids went to
school together and he and I went to
college together and um
yeah it's a lot so
ET was with boss's longtime friend Jody
Sweetin shortly after the tragic news
broke he's such a talent and such an
amazing warm wonderful heart and uh yeah
he will be he will be greatly missed
[Music]